hi everyone so I just thought I'd make
this video because I didn't want to
leave things on a bad note yes I did
some kind of upset in the video
yesterday but I really I really wasn't
upset I was just frustrated another
thing that I probably won't do again I
didn't realize it would kind of cause a
witch hunt against meap's I really
appreciate what meats said I'm high it's
probably gonna affect my channel in the
future I have said in a comment
underneath Mapes his response then I'll
take the video down if he wants a so I
pinned Mapes this comment because he
deserves that comment and he deserves
the right to kind of say his piece
without it getting buried and in all the
comments I think it was a very fair
response I agree with pretty much
everything he said again I don't want
people coming after the guy I mean it's
my fault
ultimately for putting them front and
center in the video I understand that
there was a guy in the comments that
said the video makes me seem sensitive
and patty I can see that I can see that
it's brought it's probably never gonna
happen again I think that comment just
really hit home and I really wanted to
talk about it I just shouldn't have
included his name that's Toni the only
difference just to end things and I'm
just gonna read out a few a few positive
comments because there was a lot of
support and I'm really thankful for all
the support people left on that video
yesterday there was some really really
cool emails as well some some people
sent and I want you to know one more
really appreciative of not
so as I'm reading like these positive
comments I'm gonna stick to my new rule
and that's to never call anybody out by
name in a comment video that I do so
every comment I read I'm just gonna say
somebody said okay
somebody says weird people think this I
find your channel because of your SCP
readings which is cool because that
means my channel has grown a little bit
so thank you somebody says I'll be
honest if it's a volgen video I'll watch
her listen to it you're right he makes
good points he makes bad points but what
I think is the most telling in this
video is that you're willing to at least
address criticism warranted or not not
say it I think you're doing fine not
everything will succeed but so far I
have yet to find a video of yours that I
haven't liked it all the let's play is
all right not my favorite but it's a
mostly SCP themed channel I can
understand the gameplay as to the
emotion thing you're right if he thinks
your voice is boring he probably isn't
aware while boring actually is the music
thing I can understand I've had the same
issue but that's because I have my
volume low because some people are
[ __ ] that throw and loud noises
randomly in their videos yep I think
we've all been there
at some stage watching YouTube videos
somebody says the only reason I stick
around are for the SCP reading series so
I got a lot of comments like that so the
the SCP document readings aren't gonna
go away I'm just gonna try and make them
better I think that's fair somebody says
good mod not many people respond to
criticism on YouTube you're doing God's
work lot well thanks very much
I plan to respond to any criticism with
respect but probably not like this in
the future because it caused the person
that wrote the comment probably a lot of
hassle and that's on me so that's
probably never gonna happen again
I'm gonna call it my idea because he was
the he was the kind of the point of the
last video this is a screenshot that I
got yesterday morning I felt so bad but
also I loved so much
whenever I seen this coming just Mapes
in oh [ __ ] wat okay somebody also said
this is a really this is a really long
one well I think it was really cool
so I'm gonna read it meeps basically
said what we were all thinking and they
constructed that greatly there's already
a shitload of SCP readings on YouTube
which I always thought was a perfect
time waster about a year or two ago I
came across your lumbar details and
instantly subscribed something like that
on the doctor wonder team of videos
probably got more views than the reads
I'm not saying you should stop it
altogether
you should do what Mapes add and just be
unique you don't have to be Brent
Daniels and odd music commotion around
beings which wouldn't be bad but only if
you have the time but rather do what I
thought was unique about you add more
accents when I first came across your
SCP videos not the lumbar details I
thought you were gonna be another
American not making fun of them this is
just my opinion making a channel
dedicated to the SCP franchise which I
kept thinking to myself another one
don't we have enough
well I stuck around to hear what else
she created and eventually fell upon the
lumbar details I knew you had treat on
you give a character life that no one
else could recreate that rough badassery
voice she gave him is what caught my
ears mostly because I'm from New Zealand
and everyone here loves not accent under
dr. clef video that gave me chills I'm
not even sure that you'll read this
surprise but for the off chance that you
do just know that even if you lose
subscribers or get less views than
before just note the rest of us will do
our best to support you through anything
that you make for us
and we'll try our best to keep you
within the SCP family you don't have to
impress us too much with visuals my
China was time-consuming but only if you
can spice it up in a way sorry for the
rambling I just hope you'll consider
this even though it's not as well
thought I like it names his comment I
still love your content though and I
hope you'll continue playing games or
maybe even do live streams to know the
man behind the mic you're quite the
talented Irish mom and I love any videos
that you make just don't give up I don't
let depression hold you dine well I
signed a depress but I wasn't depressed
but the sentiment is still there and I
really appreciate it thank you very much
somebody says I like the narrations but
they do get boring with just clean
generic videos the voice acting and
stuff like actual SCP voices and the
class the orientation video were fun but
the new ones are generic and boring
there was a lot of comments like this
and this is then I accept this I'm gonna
try my best to make the SCP documents
better in the future okay so that's just
a few positive comments that I've read I
just wanted to read some positive ones
just a bit of balance into the mix
finally what I'm gonna do is read out
some suggestions that people made that I
thought were really cool I'm probably
I'm gonna try and implement in the
future somebody said this may be a
personal and epic I don't really know
how difficult it would be if you could
organize your content with the playlists
then that would be nice if you put all
these seemingly random scps into a
folder with a title describing their
relation to one another I'd still be
happy this is something I planned on
doing anyway because the SCPD documents
inbreeding right now are part of the
heritage collection so what I planned on
doing was organizing these into a
playlist I've said before I really like
doing things in in series and groups
okay so I'm not gonna be doing you know
SCP series 1 0.99 or anything
I mean you know collections like Commons
collections of stories you know the
tales of mr. collector is ironically a
collection the Lombardi tales is a
really cool collection at certain SCP
documents do fall into a collection so I
am gonna be organizing them I have just
went until I've completed the heritage
collection first before I organize them
in a playlist I'm toying with the idea
of maybe combining them all into one
massive video I'm not sure though I'm
not sure about that so that's the first
idea that I probably I'm gonna do
because as I said I I was haunted in my
head before I read the comment anyway
somebody writes hey do you think you
could start doing SCP theories because
that's not something we see in the
community a lot this is another solid
idea I like this I like the idea of this
this is slightly harder because I'm
slightly dyslexic so writing stuff is
difficult for me but it's definitely
something I want to try SCP theories is
a solid idea so yeah I'm gonna make I'm
gonna maybe try to do that at some stage
definitely someone writes you want the
tip be wise steal information from the
foundation all the time take the rule of
an info liquor host what scrambled data
you can find out whatever clearance
level you can get also be wary of
memetic hazards they tend to be hidden
in high security files on blah blah blah
this was kind of a role-play comment but
still is a pretty cool idea maybe doing
SCP documents as a character from you
know like a group of interest like you
know the chaos insurgency or the GOC or
something like but i think that's a
pretty solid idea let me know what you
think about that is it got a lot of
neurons firing in my head whenever I
read that comment
so yeah but that's a few comments that I
thought I looked at one yeah that's a
pretty good idea that's the pot some of
the some of the positive comments it was
a very very discussion yes the video but
that's some of the positive comments at
some suggestions that I am I'm gonna
take on board and try and incorporate
into my videos and lastly I'm just gonna
cover what am I going to change there's
gonna be no drastic changes okay what I
am gonna do is from now on just to make
things easier this is really no kind of
extra effort on my part is each video
I'm gonna end the thumbnail I'm gonna
label maybe in the bottom left hand
corner or or somewhere noticeable I'm
gonna label it like I'm gonna label like
document or do see for document or you
know tail for tail because it doesn't
really need abbreviated so you so people
who want to filter the content that they
they would prefer to see you can do it
more easily I think that's a pretty good
idea another small change I'm gonna make
is I am gonna try and approach the
documents in a different more interest
in way at the end of the day I'm always
gonna be reading the documents but hey I
do it can't change it maybe that's even
better if I read them in a different way
every single time maybe not every single
time but most times I I think that'll be
pretty cool but anyway this that this
video is really long in summary for the
end Mapes I love I love Mapes Sam -
thank you - makes place because he
started this whole thing and it's gonna
end up making my channel so much better
I can tell so thank you meap's second of
all my content is gonna be getting
better I'm not saying
thank you very much for listening to me
once again I probably won't make a video
like this again for a very long time
goodbye everyone and thanks again for
all your support
you